what i want to do in the next few videos
is try to see what happens to a line
integral either a line integral over a
scalar field or a vector field but what
happens that line integral when we
change the direction of our path so
let's say when i say change direction
let's say that i have some curve c
that looks something like this let me
draw the x and y axis
so that's my y axis that is my x-axis
and let's say
my parametrization starts there and then
as t increases ends up over there just
like that so it's moving in that
direction
and when i say i reverse the path we
could define another curve let's call it
minus c
that looks something like this
that is my y-axis that is my x-axis and
it looks exactly the same but it starts
up here
and then as t increases it goes down to
the starting point of the other curve so
it's the exact same shape of a curve but
it goes in the opposite direction so
what i'm going to do in this video is
just understand how we can construct a
parametrization like this and hopefully
understand it pretty well and in the
next two videos after this we'll try to
see what this actually does to the line
integral one for a scalar field and then
one for a vector field so let's just say
this parametrization right here this is
to find in the basic way that we've
always defined them let's say that this
is x is equal to x of t
y
is equal to y of t
and let's say this is from t is equal
or t let me write it this way t is
t starts at a so t is greater than or
equal to a and it goes up to
up to b so in this example this was
when t is equal to a and the point right
here the point right here is the
coordinate x of a
y of a
and then when t is equal to b up here
this is
really just a review of what we've seen
before really just a review of
parametrization when t is equal to b up
here this is the point x of b x of b
y of b
nothing new there
now given these functions how can we
construct another parametrization here
that has the same shape but go that
starts here so i want this to be t is
equal to a let me switch colors
let me switch
to maybe
magenta so i want this to be t is equal
to a and as t increases i want this to
be t equals b so i want to move i want
to move in the opposite direction so
when t is equal to a
i want my coordinate to still be x of b
x of b
y of b
when t is equal to a i want a b in each
of these functions and when t is equal
to b i want the coordinate to be
x of a
y of a
right notice they're opposites now here
t is equal to a x of a y of a here t is
equal to b our endpoint now i'm at this
coordinate x of a
y of a so how do i construct that
well
if you think about it when t is equal to
a we want we want both of these
functions to evaluate it at b so what if
we define our x in this case for our
minus c curve what if we say x
is equal to
x of and when i say x if i'm talking
about the same exact function actually
maybe i should write it in that same
exact color
x of but instead of putting t in there
instead of putting a straight up t in
there what if i put an a plus b
minus
t in there
what happen well let me do it for the y
as well so and our y
y
is equal to
y of
a plus b minus t
a plus b
minus t i'm using slightly different
shades of yellow might be a little
disconcerting
anyway what happens when we define this
when t is equal to a
when t is equal to a
and let's say that this parametrization
is also for t starts at a and then goes
up to b so let's just experiment and
confirm that this parametrization really
is the same thing as this thing but it
goes in an opposite direction or at
least confirm in our minds intuitively
so when t is equal to a
when t is equal to a
x
will be equal to
x of
a
plus b
minus a right this is when t is equal to
a so minus t or minus a
which is equal to what well a minus a
cancel out that's equal to
x of b
similarly when t is equal to a y will be
equal to
y of
a plus b minus a the a's cancel out so
it's equal to y of b
so that worked when t is equal to a
my parametrization evaluates to the
coordinate x of b y of b when t is equal
to a
x of b y of b and then we can do the
exact same thing when t is equal to
b
i'll do it over here because i don't
want to lose this let me just draw a
line here
let me i'm just still dealing with this
parametrization over here actually let
me scroll over to the right just so that
i don't want to get confused when t is
equal to b
when t is equal to b what does x equal x
is equal to x of a plus b minus b
right a plus b minus b when t is equal
to b so that's equal to
x of a
and then when
t is equal to b y is equal to y of a
plus b minus b
and of course that's going to be equal
to y of a so the endpoints work and if
you think about it intuitively
as t increases
so when t is at a this thing is going to
be x of b y of b we saw that down here
now as t increases as t increases
we're going to this value is going to
decrease we start at x b y of b and as t
increases this value is going to
decrease
to a right it starts from b and it goes
to a this one obviously starts at a and
it goes to b so hopefully that should
give you the intuition why this is the
exact same curve as that it just goes in
a completely opposite direction now with
that out of the way if you accept what
i've told you that these are really the
same parameterizations just opposite
directions i shouldn't say same
parameterization same curve going in an
opposite direction or the same path
going in the opposite direction in the
next video i'm going to see what happens
when we evaluate this line integral
f of x
d s
versus
this line integral so the same so this
is the uh a scalar field the a line
integral of a scalar field using this
curve or this path but what happens if
we take this the same line or the if we
take a line integral over the same
scalar field
but we do it over this reverse path
that's what we're going to do in the
next video and in the video after that
we'll do it for vector fields